une petite nouveauté pour vous s'appelle
le mix tête et un petit jingle vous
allez voir d'être indigne va arriver oui
je vais beaucoup bien passion mais c'est
pas moi c'est donc un photographe
québécois eric collette qui a voulu voir
les similitudes de visage entre les
membres d'une même famille on reconnaît
là normalement l'extrait voilà voyait
alors frère une soeur un père un fils il
fait des portraits génétique comme vous
le voyez prend donc la moitié d'un
visage qui colle avec une autre moitié
de visage une autre personne
alors ici on est une grande famille où
je me suis dit tiens on va voir on va
faire une chose et certains chroniqueurs
parlent à quoi ça ressemblerait sur
mixer les visages d'isabelle morini bosc
et gilles verdez sa chambre le bien les
brise à gaza semble bien la phrase
placebo c'est ça ça semble bien ça
semble bien le principe à droite à
gauche où on sait qu'entre c'est l'amour
fou donc à quoi ressemblerait le mix de
maxime gagné matthieu delormeau paris
c'est même la moustache est bâti oui
c'est maxime je crois que c'est valérie
[Rires]
alors ici on mixe les visages de king de
la bafouille benjamin castaldi jean
michel maire ça comme ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi même les jo s'il termine
très bon et c'est de faire ça mais sans
lui mais le gamma mais on le voit partir
je vais aller pas l'orgie sur la
nouvelle star il n'avait pas les yeux
comme ça ça reste à se rétrécir frère il
a des anchois la place de choix ici mon
père on les voit c'est ma marque presima
mais ça rigolait mais c'est ma tête
c'est comme ça ici là résume bordel mais
ça m'a bien fait rire on dit alors
rigolé rigoler on va pas droit de
conduire
[Applaudissements]
mais vous voyez blanc pas oui je vois
très bien
est-ce que tout a rapetissé chez moi
puisque j'ai vu tout à l'heure dans la
laque ce salon perfide et j'avais envie
de mixer les têtes de cyril hanouna et
un certain hervé pavy si on peut
d'ailleurs parlé pendant cette façon ça
va aller gens m'ont vu un
on est d'accord sur benjamin on est
d'accord avec ça mais là merci jean
pierre voulait faire gamme le mix en
creux entre votre tête si reed et un
certain mohamed benyamna j'adore le
bouder regardez ça va
mais faire ça passerait pas très bien vu
que j'avais fait la pige à l'avant et
bout des rues j'embrasse que c'est la
meilleur de tt fixe mais il fera chaud
qu elle est belle ça paie le luxe est
horrible namibiens qui t'ont fait les
yeux trombe mais ya pas de noms mais on
a pris la moitié a aucun trafic
moitié-moitié points on n'a pas le temps
de faire plus à écouter bas